Luke we're here it collects ammonia you
had some big ole moments the neighbor
Thrones Season three haven't you yeah
mine's been a-been good one right few
fun what was it like killing off Lord
more ones
Joe it was absolutely terrifying the
thighs from 10-round that she's choking
any second that man is massive you know
he's an absolute absolute monster you
know it's been a weird one killing off
and James Cosmo quite bad about it but
she wasn't it somebody else he kills me
in the books isn't it so and actually
your role was expanded from season one
as well was it you know any of those
supposed to be in the first three
episodes of that how did that feel
ridiculous like I think initially I
supposed to me do like an episode in the
first season ended up staying and it's
been great man I'm like over the moon to
be here you know was it might you
character rats that you really enjoy
playing I think coming off James cousin
was the best thing possible tapping in
the whole show to be honest with you but
it's good money like so it's the best
thing about the whole thing's been
around all those all those other actors
IPO Vaughn and James Cosmo and I believe
it's like cost like most life story line
of the system enraged I mean mark and
John and Kate like it's good fun they
know what it's like being on set on this
location and Iceland is the coldest
place in the world I think
that was that was a pretty awesome
experience you know like my country's
really come like four hours of daylight
and then severe in the Northern Lights
and then it's freezing then you swimming
in open pools and the in the mountains
unbelievable country unbelievable
country but it's supposed to be the sets
been amazing it's been a really nice
experience like I think the directors
here obviously
Dave and Dan I just like really because
the so go to their job it's a really
calm atmosphere and a great time
complainers keep this season haven't you
and you've not actually been a fan of
Samwell Tarly either have you know
Christ is not exactly very nice man but
Sam's lovely so what is your problem
with him know anything okay wet
time but John's lovely that's alright
but something you know I just think he
them don't know there's a rational
dislike really they're gonna get worse
from here on in I couldn't say but yeah
Eddie Nastya cause II think that you're
pretty nasty piece of work already he's
a nice guy you know it's just
misunderstood I think I mean he's had a
hard time of it
I think actually actually think about
he's probably only good character in the
whole story realistically he's used to
nothing wrong you know he's starving so
he had to have to take action the only
bad thing is done probably is the right
thing which is a crime today's a pretty
bad thing to do apart from that I think
he's doing good cards the whole story
nobody else not that well you know one
somewhat early you know he's a coward
he's got like no water this rust is
honest could be controversial I think
maybe I'll put this claim of that I
might be I might be wrong if you see
this boy what would you like to happen
what you looking forward to is season
four um from the books or Joe I'd be
really if one thing looking out this
elevators to be a part of one those big
battle scenes Lobby ace but I don't know
happens the story so I think no coming
back so you know who knows that would be
ace keeping yourself a nurse on
tenterhooks pain like me all the time
now if you were trust in the story who
would you like to be any other character
well I thought I was perfect for for
Jaime Lannister actually I thought that
was perfect casting so no honestly I
suppose Joe I love them
koloth Hills part you know various
amazing amazing I think it's great
Oh written Guillen's little finger the
both actually do what they're all
awesome I'd do anything
maybe hot pie have a good casting right
do a hot pie who do you think in a fight
between Jamie Lannister a rat
probably probably Jamie Lannister
realistically and less like you unless
you have like no hands maybe Raska
seaside maybe maybe but I've been your
favorite moments on the show either for
brassed or just more generally for the
other characters as well another
storyline for us like doing what the
stuff in season 1 was awesome without
because it's like this is my first job
left drama school and then suddenly you
know had all this weird stuff with the
dog try that bit it's at this lake house
spend a whole like afternoon with his
dog lag on my face on a bed that was
quite good fun in fact was such an odd
job like you know you go from that to
walking around Iceland in like a coat
and then killing James Cosmo it's been a
pretty weird weirder line basically what
they do was they lay dying on the bed I
was laying on the bed and this dog's
butt skunk growl in my face
Bobby's made the dog growl to God do
something so they put like him bit of
meat on my head just like there so it's
like panting you know I was absolutely
absolutely pouring myself VR for a
thought knew I am suffering for the Arts
now tell me who you think your favourite
characters in the show ones that you
actually love seeing their storyline
yeah Joe actually a lot of Oh Jon Snow
storyline and in a way I shouldn't say
this but I realize that somewhere
storyline yeah I really want like
something happened to him that's awesome
soon to redeem himself I think it's all
awesome I mean Pete do you think
pictures like I just think he's one of
the best actors of all time I it's
amazing just like be near him even not
working with him just be around them you
know what kind of qualities you think
you need to survive in Game of Thrones
and distressed have Wyatt Oaks
I think Russell goes that would take
sees Ruth this is Viper is ruthless you
know it's just I
I think I think being desperate answers
a lot of those questions you know if you
were throwing back into a situation if
it was you in that in that world how do
you think you'd make out I'd I'd be dead
by now notice that a long time ago I
think before the battle happened I might
have been dead which is like walking up
there what he would kill me hard enough
get the milton keynes to be part of game
with fernsley SP honestly there's been
there's been the best I've done my like
it's been absolutely amazing it's been
like it's been like sounds really really
super lights been a massive honor to be
a part of a project that's got such a
massive following and like it's such a
significant part like our cultural
identity now it's been a massive honour
unto to being it more than a little tiny
bit who knows a small part you know it's
been it's been a two-month brass had to
meet his maker on the show how do you
like to see him go out so what from like
an external perspective like objectively
some more time to kill him but like
realistically like
just wander off into the woods on his
own never come back it's a pride in our
right yeah
and finally if you've got something
you'd like to say to the fans who are
watching this video
I say honestly like thank you so much
for like being around my may the fun
presence has been unbelievable since we
first started doing this you know I just
feel like massive got a little bit part
of it and I hope I hope you like it
you